yeah yeah hi how you doing man welcome
I'm good man how are you guys pretty
good pretty good so um uh Angel
mentioned before a very interesting
question I think all three of us are
curious
what's your stance on young Don
um denouncing the trinity
oh yeah I think it's a a misguided uh
conclusion obviously
um but you know he's a good dude and
he's open for conversation so I like
that
um I did a response I did like a video
where I gave my thoughts on that and so
yeah but by the way guys am I am I able
to uh like would you guys allow me to
you know use this also on my YouTube
channel as well yeah for sure man
I appreciate it of course appreciate it
but yeah like it's uh you know obviously
that's disappointing because obviously I
believe you know that you know the
Trinity is obviously the truth so
um yeah I just I just think it's a
misguided conclusion you know I see
pretty much so I want to know a little
bit more about you
were you always a Christian or did you
become kind of like born again as they
say
yeah yeah I've been uh I've been raised
into this like Believing on the Bible
and its values and stuff like that and
uh it was about when I was about 17 is
when I was like I completely surrendered
you know to to to God and
what I believe he was calling me to do
so so yeah I would say that 17 is when I
was like took it serious yeah but yeah
like growing up I've always believed no
yeah
yeah but honestly that's exactly like me
but with Islam like I grew up like a
western life like I had the fundamentals
I had like the morality and stuff but
like I didn't have anything else to
really back it and then when I hit 16
like everything changed yeah yeah that's
usually how it goes man you you learn
you learn the why you believe like later
on as you get older right as you mature
and stuff
digging deep into that stuff yes exactly
and you begin to realize the importance
of it as well you know you really
realize why religion is important
yeah I agree man I agree wholeheartedly
and so
um I I with with me and my journey like
I've noticed um
when I started to engage with Islam What
drew me to start engaging with Islam is
that Islams seem to have guys that were
really
like confident you know so confident and
grounded in this truth and so it made me
interested like okay what do these guys
have to say so obviously it started off
with a bunch of soccer Nike videos
popping up and stuff and I'm a DDOT and
stuff like that and uh it really
intrigued me it really did and so I
started digging into it and stuff like
that start studying it a bit and um and
just comparing it to what
what uh the Bible says and things of
this nature and so
I don't know like for Islam has always
been like
for the longest for me out of all like
the different religious groups been the
funnest to engage with
all right all the other all the other
people are kind of like
scared or low-key you know like the the
Jehovah's Witnesses they don't want to
they don't have streams like this you
guys posting up and streaming they don't
do this Mormons don't do this but the
Muslims like Muslims do this they're not
afraid to stream and talk and set up
tents so yeah yeah
so if I have two questions
I will turn my camera on but for some
reason Discord is turning me into
Slenderman
[Laughter]
all right for sure all right so let me
shoot first question yeah third when you
you said it was 17 or 16. it's about 17
years old so what exactly was this
pivotal moment for you
uh just I think I think it was just um
so you know my my parents they were they
were preachers and leaders of the church
and so
when I started to get involved and I saw
the impact of
um
you know how how the Bible you know has
on people that receive a message if
they're uneducated whatever and the
impact that it has on the lives of
people and it's changing them and it's
and it does these things
um it was like I was like yeah you know
this is for sure what
I'm supposed to be doing I'm supposed to
be
proclaiming this and preaching this is
what he's using me to do this you know
that's how I saw it and uh and I just
wanted to get grounded in the scriptures
myself and know it all and
and just go wherever God took me fully
you know and so so that's what I guess
that's what did is just I saw the effect
of it of the Bible and its teachings on
on people and in my life too so
yeah
okay understood
And in regards to Young Don you said it
was a
a misguided conclusion that he's come to
yeah so I would love to know your
thoughts yeah
um you know it just means that I believe
that the scripture is pretty clear that
God is Triune
um to argue from the scripture that God
is Not Triune uh
is impossible if you're going to be
intellectually honest and
use the scripture contextually and so we
could dive into that I'm open to it and
um but yeah I just think that it's the
the Trinity the Triune nature of God is
is scripturally foundational
well okay so that that's actually very
interesting so would you say that like
let's say like the Old Testament in
isolation would you say that that also
is very clear about God being a Triune
God
yeah yeah you can draw the the Triune
concept of God
from the from the Old Testament what I
would say though to be clear is that
um Jesus he's the one who like brings a
lot of clarity to the nature of God and
what he is and what he was like and
things of his nature so
um without the Revelation that Jesus
gives us it's hard to just make like
solid foundational conclusions type of
thing so it's it is like you are kind of
working backwards after you see Jesus in
relationship with him and the father in
the spirit and how they coincide with
each other that you go back into the Old
Testament and you see it pretty clearly
like yo I see like it's right there type
of thing so
that was an interesting question yeah I
mean but yeah so go ahead I was just
gonna say I really I appreciate the
honesty because um I think that there
there are a lot of people that would say
no it's clear in the Old Testament and
that's it but I do appreciate honestly
that like you do have to start with the
New Testament and then take that
understanding and then back project it
and then you can see like the you know
the the remnants are like you know you
that it could be understood in that way
um yeah uh I I think yeah I think when
it comes to the conclusion of the
Trinity yeah like
um when you come if you're just looking
at the Old Testament uh it is it is
clear that God has a plurality within
his Essence like that you don't need the
Old Testament for that but getting the
details of that
um yeah you need you need the revelation
of Christ that gives you that
the you know who the persons are and you
know really specifically like that okay
so the Old Testament it's a good little
good it gives good evidence of it
okay and I think uh so let's let's kind
of go in the order that uh that you
described it so you start with the New
Testament what Jesus said and then you
you can see it in the in the Old
Testament so what would you say is clear
in the New Testament about Jesus is
teaching and how it leads to the trinity
yeah so
um obviously so Jesus clearly taught
that the that there's only one God not
that there was only one God
um he identified the father as God
um but then you also have him
identifying himself as God as well that
yet distinct from the father and we can
go into these details obviously that's
this is the most controversial part
obviously is Jesus divine but just just
giving a summary of my view on it right
um so you see Jesus
claiming things doing things about
himself
Divine prerogatives and claiming to be
God and such this and then you also have
the Holy Spirit who is said to be God
who's said to be Eternal who said to be
a half personhood and just yet distinct
from the Son and the father and they all
work together in communion and do
everything together whether it's the
work of Salvation with the work of
creation everything they do everything
together and so you see that the New
Testament teaches clearly that these
three distinct persons yet they're
distinct are not separate in like in
their beings in their nature there of
one Essence together
so that's what I see from the New
Testament all of the New Testament okay
and I'm excited to expand on this a
little bit more so before we do I do I
want to say so it really seems like
um all of this is is relying on what
Jesus said about it in the New Testament
and and how it's it's taught in
portrayed in the New Testament correct
uh I mean just from this angle yes yes
like when you get the details so you
don't need what I this is what I would
say like without a shot of a doubt you
do not need the New Testament to
understand that God has a plural nature
that within the one essence of God there
is a plurality you don't need the New
Testament for that that's pretty
explicit throughout the Old Testament
um can you define neutrality
what does it mean yeah that that that
God is multi-personal that the one God
is multi-personal within his Essence is
is that how the uh the the rabbis and
the children of Israel and and you know
the uh people some of them yeah exegesis
yeah a lot of a lot of them did yeah
so you have you have a lot of them that
had this uh this view uh you know you
have a lot of what it's called um uh the
two powers of Heaven for example have
you guys heard of that before no I have
heard of like candletheistic Jews who
are influenced by like Greek philosophy
and stuff but oh yeah this is way but
this is way before this so I I encourage
you guys to check out uh Dr Michael
Heiser he recently passed away
unfortunately but
um he was really good in in this type of
study uh and he gives he breaks down the
the two powers of Heaven this view that
the Jews had and a lot of exegetes had
of
um of God basically it's kind of like
benatarianism almost that there were two
Powers who were God right the one God
two persons who are God you have the
son of man Divine figure and then the
Ancient of Days
and so they see them as as equal in
essence and things of this nature and so
forth and so on
so yeah so you you find evidence and
remnants of this in even uh you know
Jewish exegetes that God is plural in
this essence
all right very interesting really
interesting yeah it is it is yeah
definitely the Deep dive yeah yeah yeah
absolutely definitely something to look
into so I said I did say I want to
expand all the New Testaments kind of um
understanding or or demonstration of of
God so you mentioned that Jesus said
that you know the father is God and that
I don't think anyone would disagree with
um but honestly the main quest the main
question is you know where did Jesus say
he was God so what would you say is
evidence for Jesus saying he is God in
the New Testament
yeah so a clear one that I I think
um besides other implicit statements
that he has
um there's there's the claim to be uh
the first and the last the Alpha and the
Omega the beginning and the end in the
Book of Revelation
and so
we we all know and understand like at
the first and the last this is the one
who is God the one who has no beginning
and no end right and this is something
that we can relate to even as Muslims
are Christians that like even the Quran
says in chapter 57 verse 3 that Allah he
is the first and he is the last right so
this is one of or two of like the first
and then the other word is the last
those are two of the 99 names that you
know get revealed from Allah right so we
see this title that Jesus applies to
himself in Revelation chapter 1 verse 17
he says I am the first and I am the last
the living one
so that right there is a direct claim to
be God we even see that in the in the
Old Testament that Yahweh claims to be
the first and last over and over again
so I would say that that is an explicit
one where he claims to be God okay so
about that one the Book of Revelation
um is this a book that was written about
Jesus like the gospels were or like
what's the nature of the book
it's uh it's it's a more of a
um like revelatory book more not not so
much like uh like the gospels are more
of like a was it biography or I always
get these confused when someone is
writing about someone's life because
that's what the gospel is I always get
those confused if it's buying for your
autobiography I think it's right
um okay all right if we're wrong I'm
blaming you bro
all right
three of us was exposed man
yeah
no but um
so yeah so so yeah those are biographies
this one is is like a type of end times
uh you know Revelation type of you know
um theology you know and so it's like
it's a it's a it's a vision Revelation
that God gives to John and he's
experiencing these things getting
visitation from Jesus himself
um and seeing a lot of things happening
and things of this nature okay all right
interesting so
the the main I think
I don't want to say issue because I feel
like that's a bit
um
a bit direct but something that I think
is is important to highlight is
obviously all of this relies on the
authenticity the accuracy and the the
historical coherency of the New
Testament
so when you look at the New Testament
when you read it when you study it what
encourages you to see it as a book that
is historically reliable that is
authentic and that does go back to Jesus
in his authentic teachings being that
there were different views on who he was
and what he claimed in you know very
very early for like for a century well
that's a that's that's a that's a good
question but
um I want to kind of contend against
that just for a second yeah feel free
that
um because right right now we're just
talking about
if this is even in the text at all right
if this Trinity Doctrine or the Divinity
of Christ is actually in the text so
whether or not the text is reliable or
unreliable yeah that is a that is a a
legit question but it's a separate
question altogether yeah absolutely yeah
it absolutely is 100 it has nothing
directly to do with the conversation
except that this conversation is
predicated on that question being
answered with yes it is authentic for
sure for sure but so that was not that
was not like a rebuttal or anything it
was a genuine question oh yeah yeah and
yeah I get it yeah yeah and and I I love
your approach bro like seriously um I
know there's a lot of stuff said about
people there ideas or whatever but
um I'm having a pleasant time right now
man so I think I appreciate the approach
but yeah so
um what I why why do I take the Bible to
be reliable because uh they are multiple
independent sources
um they uh we have uh early church who
that have never
never condem contended like for example
they never disputed Matthew Mark Luke
and John those gospels have always been
in circulation from the early church
fathers who've been quoted by the church
used by the church and authoritative
according to the tradition and so
um
and there's no dispute there was never a
dispute early in the Church of who wrote
Matthew Mark Luke and John right and so
um
in the early church so like amongst the
church fathers no one ever disputed that
so
um we have and then we have also other
other writings of antiquity that kind of
that tend to cooperate like for example
the crucifixion event of Jesus tacitus
planting the younger things of this
nature so with its historical basis
um and it's early you know considered
with all things considered it's early
it's earlier than
um that's you know then what other
historical figures have to them like uh
Caesar or Alexander the Great the gospel
writings in the New Testament is earlier
or closer to the time of Jesus than the
writings are for those people that's
like real close to their life that Gap
is a lot bigger than it is for the gap
of Jesus so historically speaking it
meets the
it meets that criteria like it's pretty
good
so
those are just a few reasons I got some
more stuff in my notes that I can't
really think of though but that's just
off the top of my head no worries no
worries bro so I I'm I'm interested in I
think two maybe three things so firstly
you mentioned that no early Church
Father disagreed with the authors of it
um yeah did any of them
let me phrase this in a in a specific
way so you hear a lot that a lot of new
testament Scholars say that the gospels
were written anonymously and people like
Bart Roman will will say that the name
Mark Matthew Luke and John was added
later you know conveniently is what he
says so were these Church fathers all
assuming that they came from disciples
or was there external evidence to prove
it to them
you know so you when we're talking about
early church fathers we're talking about
people who knew the apostles we're
talking about papias who was a direct
disciple of John polycarb direct
disciple of John Clement of Rome like
some even say because Clement is
mentioned in the Bible in one of Paul's
letters and so uh there's discussion on
whether if that's specifically Clinton
the Clinton of Rome that we find in
early church history but like so
um these people are
are they knew the apostles they knew the
disciples and they never like literally
there's no evidence among them
disagreeing on who wrote who the authors
were ever right and uh so when you say
when they say Anonymous like when
barterman says anonymous
is could be misleading Anonymous when it
comes to textual criticism is not we
don't know who wrote it even though
that's what BART Irma would say uh we
don't know who the gospel writers are
but that's not what when he says
Anonymous specifically he doesn't really
mean that he means that the authors did
not put their names in the document
which was normal
um when it comes when it came to a lot
of works of antiquity at that time like
Josephus for example in some of his
Works uh wrote in the third person said
literally was a man Joseph went and did
this yada yada we have a lot of this
type of stuff this type of style of
writings so I don't think it's
um I don't think it's any Credence to
say oh
the Matthew Mark Luke and John did not
write it because their names aren't in
it when we have early testimony
Undisputed testimony that says that they
did you know so that's where the the
evidence leads for me okay so that's
that's interesting testimony you
mentioned Church Brothers testimonies
from from them and what did they say
about it
yeah so all of them all of them agree
like they say Matthew Matthew Luke
General John uh and Mark dictated his
gospel from Peter all of them agree on
this right and so
um
so you have and then you also have what
is called uh the dedicate that
um was kind of like a
uh
it had it mentioned the the books by
name Matthew wrote Matthew Luke Luke and
stuff like that
um and so you have a lot of these works
that attest to the authorship of the
gospels right and then you have the
church itself like the church as a body
the church community that always you
took these writings as authoritative and
gave and recognized the authorship of
these people but when you see these
other type of writings come up like The
Gospel of Barnabas for example or uh the
uh Gospel of Mary or Peter you see the
church fathers and the church Community
reject these writings because they are
clearly forged and they turn out not to
be written by these by the people that
they are they're written by if if I may
if I would like to push back a little
bit on on those points sure so firstly
um when when you mention that the church
fathers basically unanimously agreed
that these were written by Mark Matthew
Luke and John I think that I would like
you to expand on that a little bit
because not all of them could even read
and write and they were written
um The Originals at least in Greek so
what a lot of new assessment Scholars
say is that you have these trained very
highly skilled trained literary literary
trained Greek writers who probably wrote
In other lands
in like you know decades between like 38
to like maybe a hundred years after
Jesus peace and blessings be upon him so
when you say that they authored it are
they saying that it goes back to them or
that they actually wrote it down and
they have their copies or the copies of
the the original
yeah that they're the ones who authored
it so
um it wouldn't be a problem like for
let's say for example let's let's grant
that uh
that let's say Peter couldn't read and
write which I disagree with that there's
no evidence in the scripture that
suggests that but let's just go with it
and grab that right yeah
um that still doesn't take away that he
could have dictated the gospel right and
uh and had scribes write down what he
was what he was saying yeah no we we are
right sorry sorry just to to
specify the point I agree like the
process you know he couldn't read it
right and he had describes he would
write things down though we don't have a
problem with that I think that the point
that I want to highlight is how for him
to have
access to someone who is trained to be
that literally
um to have that level of literary
expertise to write it in the way in the
the in the the form that is written that
requires like literary elegance and and
immense eloquence with writing so it's
very unlikely that they knew how to read
it right or at least all four of them
but even if they did
or sorry even if they if they didn't
they dictated it the fact that it's so
highly eloquent is um is is the trouble
Troublesome Point historically I guess
you could say why
why because it's very um to be specific
it's very unlikely that they would have
access to someone of that skill it's
like it's like me
you know knowing like a like an NBA
player like that's how like they're very
rare is what I'm saying but not
impossible no definitely not impossible
I'm just saying it's very rare if we're
using this like this taking this
approach I'm just saying it's very rare
um not that it's absolutely impossible
okay so
um that's interesting because I I would
have to see this is what I've heard what
I've seen and I have to touch up on this
a little bit more yeah but I I haven't
heard that the gospel writings for
example except for Luke
in the book of Acts and Hebrews that
they were eloquent and things of this
nature or masterly masterfully like like
it was good writing and good grammar it
was um like they sing bro like not not
sorry not just in grammar and in
eloquence and being able to write but in
the way they tell the story and the way
they they they you know the the whole
the entire writing together is just so
like it's actually beautiful if I'm
being honest and that's something that
can only be accomplished because when
you tell a story how you tell it is
important right so it's not just being
uh being linguistically inclined it's
the way they told the story that is is
fantastic as well
yeah so this is what I'm saying um we we
have because like Matthew for example he
was a tax collector he had to have
experience in writing records and
receipts and things of this nature and
and being very calculative so we have
evidence that he could read and write
and probably sophistically uh was
sophisticated at it
um Luke obviously being the physician
that he was and the historian that he
was
um Peter not writing it but giving but
dictating it to mark
um who could read and write yeah
um and then uh who was John as well I
there's no evidence that John couldn't
read or write you know so yeah I think I
think it would be more of a a more far
stretch to say that they couldn't read
and write
um
uh or that they couldn't have someone
who knew what they were doing to write
what they were what they were speaking I
don't think that's a far stretch okay
okay I I I would disagree and just to
push back a little bit the reason is
because it's it's unlikely not only that
someone was that trained it was unlikely
that someone could read or write at all
you know you know how they say like one
in every four person is blah blah blah
blah they have these statistics right
it's even lower that one in every x
amount of people back then knew how to
write so you take four random people one
is a tax collector one is this physician
all that stuff maybe one or two of them
correct but to assume all of them could
or that they even had access to someone
who could write with that degree of
eloquence that is extremely like
statistically speaking unlikely for the
time according to to people like bar
irman and other historians but something
I do want to mention kind of as an
add-on point you mentioned that they
accepted these books because they knew
they were reliable Bart Ehrman he has
this he's been doing a series recently
with another New Testament scholar where
they mention
um I'm going to take a call in one
second but I want to make this point
okay where he mentions that the way the
church and the church fathers a lot of
them dictated what is canonical and
correct and authentic is they would see
if it agrees with their doctrines and if
it doesn't agree with their Doctrine
this is this is their logic that these
doctrines are true so if something
agrees with the doctrine it's most
likely from an eyewitness and a disciple
and if it doesn't agree with our
doctrines then it's most likely not from
a disciple so it's not that they didn't
believe they were from disciples but
their logic in how to determine whether
it was or not from a disciple was there
wasn't from a disciple was if it agreed
with what they already believed so it's
kind of backwards in terms of you know
proving something
well not necessarily because you have
this example where there was someone who
claimed to have a gospel of Peter and
they investigated and
um and and uh
out at this man for forging a writing
they knew that Peter didn't write like
they literally investigated and knew
that Peter didn't write it and they
kicked him out of the assembly
so like it's not simply because it
didn't match their theology they knew
that it was a straight-up forgery it
didn't match it didn't Peter wasn't
there Peter didn't write it the guy
never knew Peter type of thing so yeah
that's that's that but can I can I ask a
question if I if I can yes I do want you
to but let me just sorry this is on off
topic so so um we have um I'm sure you
know um ijaz Ahmed I want to ask you out
of respect you're our guest here I don't
want to you know put anyone in a in like
a discussion or debate that they didn't
sign up for
um people are saying that you just Ahmed
should come up he is available he
messaged me would he be interested in
also talking to ajaz and we can just
kind of like host it or do you want to
stick with us for
I would I would rather stick with you
guys honestly okay do you mind if I ask
why have you have you spoken to Asia
yeah yeah I spoken to him and uh we
didn't have a good run-in in fact he
really disrespected me and
um
came at me personally so okay okay this
conversation is good and great so I
would rather continue
we'll keep the personal stuff out
um give me just two seconds I'm gonna
hop off but you guys will still be live
to continue just give me two seconds all
right thank you okay all right bro
if we said that's your name correct
yeah I had a I had a question
yes if you want to ask it by all means
if not then I got the question for you
for sure so we were talking about uh the
reliability of um
of the scriptures like of the New
Testament things of this nature so as as
a Muslim as Muslims
um it seems like
the Quran is pretty clear that it speaks
well of the Gospel that speaks well of
the Torah the Psalms and things of this
nature
but when I hear about what what Muslims
I get in these conversations you guys
say that it's been corrupted and you
can't trust it and things of its nature
so how do you how do you reconcile that
um that that idea that
the books have been corrupted when the
Quran seems to say that they haven't
been and then they're intact and good
for use and guidance and judgment
okay fine would you like to go first or
would you no no go on bro I'm gonna hear
what you say
all right bro so first off man
I was not born Muslim
I was uh
born Catholic
and then I went into Christianity for a
while New Age spirituality Hinduism
Buddhism of all the isms if you can
think about it to be honest
now when I was really diving deep
into Christianity
I found
many parts that had been
removed from the Bible the original
Bible so to speak anytime that I would
ask
why why were these sections removed why
would why was this in this way any of
the pastors or any of the those people
that I had around me at the time
they never really had an answer they
would always say oh why does that matter
or you should just believe you just have
to have faith you just have to have
faith it's not that I was trying not to
have faith I was actually trying to have
more faith by understanding why
which is the whole reason I was asking
it's like a kid when a kid asks because
they're curious not because they're
trying to disprove something they're
just curious they want to know the
answer
and this for me
created a disconnect
and another thing that
I'd say was I'm not gonna say it was
that they know on the coffin because it
wasn't that there was a nail on the
coffin it was more so
that
it wasn't giving me the answers that I
was looking for so I just kept searching
in other places but the the final thing
that had done it for me was
I was looking into
the life of Jesus accused me upon him
and there was a time frame
which disappears
and then he comes back and these are
known as The The Lost Years of Jesus
Christ
and to me when I have found out about
this boy I found that so interesting and
I said
you know what we couldn't just know what
went on during this time because it
disappeared and then he came back now
he's like what he got now he's supposed
to be
the one who's running the whole
operations even just telling everyone
the truth and revealing the gospel
so I just wanted to know like what
happened during this time and everywhere
that I searched I found zero answers and
then the same thing happened is when I
would ask what happened during this time
I remember
be personal is closest or as close
as I could say and she was very very
devout Christian when I asked her about
this
she replied why does it matter
and to me it just it didn't make sense I
was like how does it not matter
something like this or the main
character in this religion who is
supposedly God is gone and then he comes
back and now he's good
because for me it was like how's this
how can you miss out on something so
important like this something yeah so
much wisdom
you know what I'm saying and the more
that I look the more that I asked again
no one had the answer no one can direct
me in the right way so it's not to say
that oh I just threw Christianity in the
trash because of this it was more so
the fact that because I wasn't finding
the answers there I continued to look
into other religions again I was not I
was not biased in any way you shape or
form and
I hope that answered the question I know
it's all over the place right
a little bit more assisting than that
it's just simply that we as Muslims
believe that the Torah and the NGO the
torat and the gospels that these are
from God in their original scriptures
but that in fact is not what we have
today
what was the question right his question
was uh in the Quran it mentions that you
know the Torah and the gospels are you
know these are every what did you
mention them as
um
I uh they're good for guidance and and
uh and judgment and intact
so okay so and that modern Muslims
there's a lot of kind of not animosity
but we look at a lot of these books like
the Bible and we say they've been
corrupted that's what he said okay so
which verse are you referring to when
you say um intact
I think that's specific like judgment
and and guidance I I want to question
that judgment I can see that um in terms
of like um
like the punishment for adultery and
that stuff because there is a Hadith
about that but in terms of guidance and
intact sorry actually one more thing so
I I spoke to ijaz he said that you know
he's willing to have a normal calm
conversation no you know personal
attacks I'm not I'm not interested I'm
not interested okay no worries I'm
Bureau with you guys like I'm loving
this Vibe right here
um me and him yeah I mean he you could
go to his channel he's made a video you
can see uh you can see it for yourselves
so I'm I'm I'm I like I like what we're
doing here so that's cool bro that's
cool yeah so yeah if you uh if you want
to continue with the answer
yeah okay yeah so uh you know what was
your question uh what verse was yeah
yeah what verse mentions like guidance
and intact
okay yeah yeah so uh so it's quite a few
of them so uh uh three verse three and
four talks about how there's guidance
and light in them and
um uh chapter 5 verse 46 talks about her
how there's gotten some light in the
gospel
um okay can we have a few verses before
sorry
one by one yeah yeah
can you pull them up I don't have a
computer you don't got your your Quran
your book man you don't got the book I'm
currently traveling bro
man you supposed to be carrying the
Quran with you man I'm disappointed
inshallah next time bro
to keep it to keep it very simple
you know in regards to my very long
answer
the Muslims they tend to
I guess you could say get very
defensive and almost put down the
scriptures that you see today in
Christianity because
they see that it has been altered and
they believe that the original gospel
that Jesus peace be upon brought down
the Torah Moses peace be upon and
brought down these these were intact and
these are the original message yeah but
over time
us Muslims have found from
their own research
that there has been these alterations so
from their own conclusions this is what
they have come to not sure some of them
may not
express it in the best way
but for the most part that is the answer
okay
do you guys you guys modified
um so Avery our friend um I do have the
Ayah here the verse so you mentioned
chapter three verses three and four so
I'm just gonna read the translation
um he has revealed to you the book in
truth confirming what came before it as
he revealed the Torah in the gospel in
verse 4 says previously as a guide for
people and also revealed the standard to
distinguish between right and wrong that
was like in parentheses
um surely those who reject Allah's
Revelations will suffer a severe torment
for Allah is Almighty capable of
punishment now what do you get from this
verse yeah to like versus pretty before
yeah yeah so this is particularly
answering the guidance part because you
asked what verse talks about there being
guidance in these scriptures so this
verse says that there was guidance and
light in the Torah in the gospel
yeah every everything that's it's saying
is that the Quran confirms what came
before what came before and that those
the those those books are have guidance
and and light in them and uh he also
revealed the the standard the Criterion
I believe is is the word there okay so
so yeah it says
um
um which means before this he revealed
the Torah in the gospel uh for mankind
so yeah I think it's very simple that he
revealed the Torah in the gospel for the
people for mankind at that time
um that doesn't mean necessarily what we
have today
is what was revealed right so there's
the discrepancy and then when he says
it's
um that's actually talking about Quran
one of the words the Quran is the fur
Khan is the it is
yeah so so where where I would
um
or I would disagree here is is where you
would you identified that Quran or the
phukan as the Quran because you're right
the Quran is called the Criterion it's
called the fukan but also the Torah is
as well the Torah is called al-fur Khan
um in chapter 21 verse 48 I believe yeah
but that the reason that doesn't make
sense to me is because he what's what's
the Ayah say he revealed to you the book
and Truth conforming what what was
before it he revealed the Torah in the
gospel so now they're talking he's
talking about the Torah in the gospel
right he revealed those before as a
guidance right
um so to say end the Criterion would
basically be saying he revealed the
Torah and the gospel in the Torah
well so here's here's my point because I
I like what you just said because I I
would agree with you that it has to be
talking about something else than what
was previously mentioned but notice how
the Quran is previous is previous
previously mentioned I mean and the
Torah and the gospel are previously
mentioned so it has to be another book
sorry which obviously what could be the
Psalms or something else what so I I I
would actually like to read the tafsira
on this though because I'm interested in
what the scholars say about that the
reason I disagree is because it the
subject changed so he says before he
says
I know he's talking about another
subject past tense before he wrote the
Quran he revealed the Torah and the
gospel right and he says
yeah but before we get there but my
point is that when he mentions the past
tense you know he's on to a new subject
that he revealed these things and
I'm very interested as to what the
scholars say about that but the reason I
distinguish is because he's moved to a
new subject right the past tense and
then he mentions al-forkan I don't think
it would be to out of whack to to
believe that he's talking about the
Quran I don't think so either I I don't
so yeah yeah I don't think it's out of
whack to say that per se but I'm just
like being being consistent so if you're
saying that the subject changed to now
talking about the books in the past
then the Torah and the gospel and
because it says and
the broken right yeah it says as a
Before Time and as guidance of light and
the for Khan so that's that's still in
conjunction with the Torah and the
gospel then it would be still be past I
guess the subject would be the books of
the past
before the Quran yeah you know you might
you might you might be on something not
that it's another book but to what the
translation of IBN
Allah says is um and he's on the down
the Criterion which is the distinction
between misguidance falsehood and
deviation on one hand and then Truth uh
guidance truth and piety on the other
hand this is because of the indication
science plain evidences and clear proofs
that it contains because of explanation
clarifications
Etc because Allah's statement truly
those who just believe that ayat of
Allah means they denied so I still could
be talking about the Quran either song
about the Quran or is talking about I
want to say another book but basically
that which distinguishes between right
and wrong which yeah I mean let's be
real I think in this context he's
talking about the Quran at this point I
I I I think it can it can you can go
either way I I would argue that it could
I would throw the Psalms in there let's
let's not the songs the songs is like
the step child I'll throw the Psalms in
there man maybe maybe I I but maybe it's
not solidified I'm not like saying like
oh that's it but you know it's a fun
idea what I remember from the Psalms
sorry sorry not to cut you off I I've
read a few of the songs and I actually I
enjoy some of them I've used them
sometimes in Arguments for Islam and
I've heard them I've heard them in
arguments uh for Christianity and that
stuff like something or something that's
interesting yeah yeah I know about those
bro I know about those but
um okay okay they seem a lot of them
seem like kind of prophetic less about
guiding and truth and falsehood but more
about like what's to come am I right it
depends yeah it depends on because
Psalms is a big book you know it's like
100 books or something chapters yeah so
uh you you have elements of of Prophecy
and you have elements of like guidance
and right living and all it's just a
bunch of genres in there man it's it's a
huge mix a huge mix all right so so just
to continue like so right so obviously
Torah in the gospel guidance and light
um now I I'm I'm arguing I'm about to
make the argument that according to the
Quran the Torah in the gospel was still
used as guidance and light and judgment
for the Jews and the Christians that
they were supposed to believe in the
Quran yes
but their judgment and guidance was
based on the Torah and the gospel that
was with them
so to expound upon that point a little
bit Allah he mentions throughout the
Quran that you know they find in their
books mention of the Prophet Salam and
if it's gonna guide them to anything it
would basically guide them to Prophet
sallam guide them to Islam and we know
from different Hadith from the town of
process there were some Jews that
actually realize the prophet sallam is a
prophet of God based on different things
one he had a seal on his back one do you
recognize that two he would not accept
charity and three I think it was he
would take care of the orphan something
along those lines so yeah they would
actually use it but it would bring them
to Islam inevitably and it summarized
with the verse I mentioned at the
beginning of the stream I don't think
you were here at that point But at the
beginning of the stream which um Allah
says basically oh people the book come
to a common word and people like to say
that this this is like basically come to
agreement with people on the book you
know people of the book coming to
someone like a girl oh you believe this
we blow that too but it's actually what
it's saying is invite them to Islam the
common word is
yeah and yes oh sorry I don't no no
sorry sorry I know I'm not on going on a
lot forgive me no but you're making
you're making good points I appreciate
that so one last point is
um on the topic of now the Jews and
Christians who don't accept Islam uh
that um they are allowed to rule with
from their book there is that level of
like they're allowed to have their own
courts and stuff based on their own
beliefs uh in in their roles but in
terms of what it calls them to follow it
calls them to follow Islam and if they
receive the message like anyone else and
then they reject it afterwards they are
considered you know disbelievers and
would be punished on a day of judgment
so so this is where this is where I
because we're talking strictly from The
quran's Stance so uh I agree with you
with a lot of what you said that they
the their scriptures would lead them to
believe that Muhammad is a prophet and
that the Quran was actually sent down as
a revelation from God like they have
literally this is this is an argument
that the Quran uses continuously
um uh against the Jews and the
Christians who reject Muhammad saying
that basically they have no reason to
reject him because it his his
prophethood confirms what their books
already say I guess he's not saying
anything different and it's confirming
what they have so they have no use they
have no reason no good reason
uh to to reject them if they're true
followers of their books they would
believe that Muhammad is a prophet right
that's an argument that the Quran
continuously uses so
um that's and that's that's what I'm
saying
uh the Quran
it it argues that the Torah and the
gospels were intact were there in the
possessions of the Jews and Christians
during the time of Muhammad and was so
valid that they were supposed to be use
it to believe in Muhammad as a prophet
to begin with that's you know yeah
that's I would say that's a bit of a
logical jump because just because
there's an aspect of it let me I mean
maybe I missed maybe no worries but
maybe I misunderstood what you're saying
but if I did you know please correct me
but I I don't think so I think you know
what I mean I think you got it so the
reason I say that's a bit of a logical
jump is because just because the aspects
of you know prophesizing the prophet
moham peace and blessed be upon Him is
in there doesn't mean the rest of it is
is preserved you know
okay so that that's that's an
interesting point so that's why uh
that's what would not make sense to me
if is if some of it is the word of God
yeah but other parts of it is corrupted
that doesn't make that I don't see that
in the Quran I don't see where the Quran
says that it confirms some of the Torah
in the gospel or parts of it but it it I
mean it literally says it literally says
this about about the previous scriptures
you cannot choose parts of it and reject
others it literally says in chapter two
uh let me try to see if I can get that
verse but yes you know you know what I'm
talking about yeah I know what you're
talking about so the the I think the the
issue is now uh I don't want to say
semantic but in in terms of when we say
Torah and in jail it doesn't necessarily
mean you know what they have with them
you know so but it says it brother it
says it it literally says what they have
with them I'm I'm thinking I'm not
making I'm not sorry I'm not commenting
on the eye this is about the last point
you made that's uh okay
um parts of it like there's no saying
that parts of it were preserved and then
some other others weren't because and
this is back to the first the chapter
three that you mentioned verse three and
four
um when it says
that doesn't necessitate you know what
they have right now with them
um and there are ayat where it says you
know do you write the scripture with
your own hand or do you write you know
things and then claim that this is from
God
um
and that you know I think there's
something along the lines of at least
like how they're they're Liars or they
they sold basically the afterlife for
for like a little bit of gain so there
is they try to sell all those Outlaws
they try to they made fake books said
it's from Allah and then tried to sell
it for a small price yeah it doesn't
have to be it doesn't yeah but it
doesn't have to be a full book it could
just be adding a few verses or or saying
anything this is scripture from God and
and writing it down and you know it
doesn't have to be a full book could be
implementation of a verse or something
there's one more thing I have to say
just sorry off topic okay I'm just out
of respect for our our brother ejaz
um
before you mentioned that that he had
some kind of personal attack against him
uh or sorry that he had a personal
attack against you um I do want to
defend the brother of the stream is uh
he denied these things said that he
never did that the stream is on his
channel if you guys want to watch uh
personally I don't know a jazz to be the
type of guy to do that and out of love
and respect for him you know I do want
to defend him
um that's okay that that's okay that's
fair
um like I said it's uh we can you guys
can go check out the video on his
channel
um and also on um
is where they did the stream and they
were you know doing these things so
anybody wants to see that stuff go there
but you know you know that's that's you
know I I'm focused on this right now
but yeah so look look
so you have
um you have
this the scripture the the the Quran
verses that say the scripture is in the
possession of the Jews and Christians
and that it confirms what is in the
possession of the Jews and the
Christians it doesn't say what's what's
part of in their possession or whatever
it says it confirms what is in their
possession period multiple times
right okay and so can you give a verse
for reference please
sure sure so you have for example uh
chapter two
verse 89
and and verse 91 same chapter verse 89
and 91.
you said 91 or 191 91.
so you have a verse verse 89 and verse
91 of chapter 2.
okay
foreign
so 89 and 91 right
okay uh translation although they used
to pray for victory
um in parentheses by means the prophet
because upon them over the polytheists
when they're when there came to them a
book from Allah they recognized
confirming the scripture
um so confirm the scripture they had in
their hands they rejected it so Allah's
condemnation uh be upon the disbelievers
okay and then 91 says
when we said to them believe in what
Allah has revealed they reply we only
believe in what has been sent down to us
and they deny what came afterwards
though it is the truth confirming their
own scriptures uh ask them a prophet why
then did you off Allah's prophets before
if you are truly Believers okay so
you're saying that this has to be
affirming everything and not a part of
it or parts of it right because it says
it affirms that which is in their
possession
let me so it doesn't say it doesn't say
part of it yeah let me let me see what
it says uh what the Arabic says
okay
it just says what was what was with them
so the Quran is confirming what was with
them right yeah
and so what was with them obviously the
Torah in the gospel yeah and the Quran
is confirming that yeah
so I think that it you you know you
would have a point if there were
somewhere in the Quran where it said
something along the lines that it is
affirming part of
Couture in the gospel are part of what
is with them and stuff but you every
time you you have this like this subject
everywhere in the Quran it's a fool just
blanket statement confirming what is
with them what is between their hands of
what is in their possession like it's
just a blanket statement yeah let me let
me let me let me push back on that a
little bit so the reason I disagree is
because this might sound silly but let
me let me say the full point so for me
it sounds like when a Muslim goes to
Christian and says show me where Jesus
says the words I am God or where he says
the words worship me Christians are
going to say well we have this this
other verse that implies that he's God
or almost maybe says he's God without
actually saying I'm God or worship me
the reason I say that is because like I
mentioned there's ayat from before where
people wrote their own scriptures wrote
the scriptures with their own hand and
basically lied about it and sold the
afterlife for a little bit right
um so since we have these ayat we know
that parts of the book have been changed
also we don't know exactly what books
they had at the time by the way like we
don't know if they're what they had is
exactly what we have today and last
point I want to make is I think it's
very clear even if what they had is what
we have today there are things that the
Quran clearly disagrees with so by
default logically it would follow that
it confirms the things that it agrees
with and then obviously would reject the
things that are different like for
example saying that Allah has a son or
something like that so I think it's it's
a logical Gap just because by itself I
think it's solid but when you bring in
this context it really in my opinion
kind of falls apart
so you made some beautiful points that
thank you I um but they're beautiful in
the way that if they need to be reversed
it's it's backwards so okay so let me
tell you why let me tell you why so
you're right that the
all right let me just let me just repeat
the point that you made specifically in
this part that okay the Quran clearly
goes against what we find in what is
known as the Torah in the gospel today
right it goes against a lot of teachings
that's in there and so it wouldn't make
sense for the Quran to be talking about
that specifically because it literally
contradicts that right so but it's it's
it's it's the other way around
because the Quran confirms the Torah in
the gospel and that's the only Torah and
gospel we've ever had right and this is
what has been in their possession and it
can it contradicts the teachings that we
find in the Torah in the gospel then
that actually doesn't go against the
Torah in the gospel that we have it goes
against the Quran because it's
confirming a book that it contradicts
so it's it's it's it's it's it's
allowing me to jump in
also I was muted uh no yeah just for a
second it was it's all good so it's just
um because you said you said a few
things I wanted to touch and not just
staying here but I know that that's kind
of a big point so I I will rest it here
and let somebody respond to that but
yeah so it it's it's the Quran confirms
the Torah in the gospel if the Quran
contradicts the Torah in the gospel
that's not the fault of the Torah of the
Gospel that's the fault of the Quran for
saying it confirms these books if if it
confirms books that it contradicts then
that would be an internal contradiction
on itself okay out on the outside books
yeah so so the reason okay this is where
I think the The Logical slip is firstly
um if if you are I'm not saying you are
because maybe or maybe you aren't if you
are conflating versus where it just says
the Torah and the gospel
um then that would be a logical slip
just because one usually what it says
that's referring to the originals like
we revealed detour in the gospel but in
this case where it mentions what they
have with them
um it seemed to be the case that you are
assuming first first you're assuming
it's talking about the whole book
and then saying that since it's talking
about the whole book and some things
disagree with it the Quran contradicts
itself what I'm saying is it's not it's
not confirming the whole book I'm saying
that that verse itself is is just saying
you know confirm what's with them
speaking about and this is just like
it's just kind of basic logic only the
things of the Quran agrees with since
there are other ayat that mentioned that
the scriptures have been changed so it's
not like a completely
um kind of unreasonable jump
Okay so
so I I get it what I'm what I would
argue is that no scripture teaches that
this that no verse in the Quran teaches
that the uh at the Torah in the gospel
have been changed and so when you when
you talk about the verse that we've been
talking about right how they woe to
those who write the book with their own
hands saying that it's from God selling
it for a small price right yeah
um is so that's not saying that they
actually went into the Torah and changed
the Torah but that they wrote of their
own hands right a fake book saying that
it's from God and that um you know that
and and trying to sell it so like and we
get this it's not I'm not just making
this up when you go into like for
example if you go into the top seer of
ibikathir he quotes IBN Abbas
um about the Distortion of the
scriptures and what that actually means
it's not textually but it's they're
distorting interpretations and meanings
and lying about what the verses say and
the scriptures say right so let me um
let me see if I can get this up really
quick here because he quotes all right
here it is
so if you go to if you go to ibika
theater's tops here in chapter 3 verse
78 right
and now it talks about um those who
distort the book with their tongues
it means that they alter them right and
he says
al-bukhari reported that IBN Abbas said
that the Ayah means they alter and add
although none among Allah's creation can
remove the words of Allah from his books
plural
so no one can remove the words of Allah
from his books but he continues and says
they alter and distort their apparent
meanings yeah so let me let me let me
explain what what this means so firstly
you quoted the Ayah that said what they
say with their tongues right and with
the eye that I mentioned before is what
they write with their hands so these are
two different things because when you
distort something in its meaning a lot
of the time or every time it's how you
explain the verse what it means in the
process he mentioned that you know
um that they would make Haram and vice
versa so like they would do this kind of
stuff themselves they would basically
give false rulings on whatever they
wanted to secondly there is an Ayah in
the Quran where Allah says the words of
Allah cannot be changed so it seems that
this is a reference yeah but the whole
dear or is this hold your horses okay it
seems
it seems like this is a um a reference
to that Ayah very clear because it
almost quotes a word for word based on
the English translation you gave and
what that Ayah means is not that
when you because by the way the Torah
and the injil are not books that you
know God has written down you know it's
it's it's it's a book in the sense that
it has it has contents beginning to end
in structure and meaning and all that
stuff that's what it means it doesn't
necessarily wait wait say that point one
more time sorry yes no no worries so
these are books in the sense that they
have a beginning an end a Content a
structure meaning that's what it means
book right
and okay um that doesn't necessarily
mean it's a physical must-have it's a
physical book so just even though
someone can't change the truth of it the
meaning of it objectively and what the
eye actually sounds like for example
Allah says uh the Karima is
it's it's talking about a decree now
that the word is a decree because when
God decrees something he only says be in
it so that's what the Kalima is that's
what the word is that's why Jesus is
called you know a word from Allah
because he said be in it same thing with
Adam B and it is a verse saying that
they're they're similar for that reason
so they must have or not the must-have
sorry the book itself not being changed
in in the this Hobby in the the tafsir
that mentions that by no means I would
imagine is talking about a a physical
writing of it or any physical writing of
it but the book itself in what it uh you
know what God actually revealed in what
actually yeah so this this is where I
would disagree because the the tough sir
it continues and it says uh
Bobby said the Torah and the angel
remain as Allah revealed them and no
letter in them was removed however the
people misguide others by addition and
false interpretation relying on books
that they wrote themselves right so the
understanding is not that they went
inside the Torah or went inside the
gospel and changed the words in the
Torah in the gospel but that they wrote
fake books books that they wrote
themselves and claimed that it's from
God I think I think you missed a big
part of the explanation which is that
they would add things in so you know
firstly yeah but but sorry yeah sorry I
don't mean that's important like I I see
that part yeah but it's saying that they
added by
uh by writing books of their own like
they're not adding or taking away from
the actual Torah or the actual gospel
but they're adding
uh and taking away from books that they
that they write themselves saying you
know like you get what I'm saying yeah
yeah the reason I think it's just a bit
of of a misunderstanding is because when
again like what these words mean when we
say take away from the Torah take away
from the gospel it's not like the Torah
and the gospel actually changed and it
could it's actually very fair to say
that when he says books that they wrote
on their own is that the book they were
on their own is that mixing the truth
with the falsehood
so that now it's a new book it's not the
Taurus not the NGO it's it's the what
basically it took from it and then they
added their own things it's not the
original anymore and that's why I think
he's saying the tour and the injeel
cannot be changed because they always it
only exists in the way that Allah
revealed it that's the only true Torah
and the only true gospel so I think it's
a bit of a Mis no I'm not saying it's
intentional but I think it's a bit of a
misrepresentation to to to take that
interpretation rather than the one that
I I gave based on the other reasoning in
the ayats that I mentioned
so so the the reason why I take this
understanding
um what's your name again do raw me
Rami Rami
okay okay cool nice to meet you bro
Romney the reason why I I take this uh
interpretation is because of what I of
the totality of verses that I see about
what the Quran says about the Torah and
the gospel bro and so when when I see
that we never see a a verse that says
that they went and changed the text of
the Torah or the text of the Gospel but
we see distortions of meanings we see uh
Distortion with their tongues you know
and lying about the verses and hiding
and all this kind of writing and writing
things with them but the writing things
yeah the writing things of their own
hands and as we enter as we see the
interpretation of this writing the
things of their own hands are them
writing their own books not going into
the Torah and the gospel and changing
the actual tour in the gospel but I I
but Habibi I explained that man I
explained that Avery
so what about it do you disagree with
where do you think I I make the mistake
okay so I think that you make the
mistake when you're saying that they
because you said it could be right it
could be that they are going into if
they're actually going into the actual
Torah right the actual Torah and the
actual gospel and they're going into
these actual books and changing things
and adding things to the actual text of
the realtor of the Gospel that's where I
think that you're that you're wrong on
this one okay yeah yeah so yeah did I
misunderstand you I think you're in a
way because you guys uh you guys are
saying your points but then it's like
y'all are hitting walls on this so
inshallah government I can explain both
of it another conclusion but it's more
easily digestible so what I'm saying is
that the original
the original Torah
these are incredible
right
now the actual Torah and engine
before it became a physical book it was
not a physical book
he was saying that it was as if he had
the structure of a book where it has the
beginning the ending and the content
that the context
now when you have the physical book
these physical books are now prone
to alteration to being changed these are
the books that can be changed that
doesn't mean that they are corrupting
the actual wait say that say that one
more time bro say that one more time
so the the books the physical book of
the Bible or the physical book of the
Old Testament the Torah
this physical book
and the altered because again the
original
was not a book in and of itself it's
Revelation it was a revelation okay and
can I can I pause you right there hold
on hold on okay all right go ahead go
ahead
so because of this what ends up
happening is that if you have something
that was original and that will always
be original but now is in a physical
book and the physical book has been
altered and what ends up happening is
that
the truth
which is the ngu the truth which is in
the Old Testament in the Torah
still there but it's now you have
instead of a hundred percent or let's
say instead of ten truths you may have
eight truths and then two things that
are alterations and there's no real way
that you will know unless
you had something where you had the
original manuscript or you knew the
exact thing for what it was before
I understand what you're saying
um so with that line of thinking do you
believe that the physical Quran
can be altered
the
um
Can can be so let me limit that it has
but Canon yeah so let me let me ask just
so I understand let me let me also I
understand that question first so when
you say do we think the the physical
Quran can be changed do you mean that
someone can make a Quran and then add a
verse or like take a Chapter or
something and I just add a verse and
print it or write it or something like
that
oh yeah or or like what what he's saying
like um like the physical because you
aside from the obviously the oral
Revelation that Allah gives that God
gives but now the when it when it's
written and now put in a physical form
could that be corrupted
yeah someone can someone can make so
yeah someone could print a Quran and
then add a verse randomly and then try
and call it the Quran but it's no longer
the Quran or it's not no longer the uh
the Quran and the Surah they change is
no longer the Surah from Allah and let
me give this example if I make a book
all right instead of saying booking to
say story because when you say book in
Arabic or sorry in English it almost
necessitates as a physical book right so
uh in Arabic it's not exactly the same
there are different words as you know
it's very specific so let's say I I had
a story I said a word for word I went
live on our podcast
verse 1 verse 2 Avery joined the podcast
verse 3 we had a great discussion and
now someone writes down those three
verses and then they add two or three
more at the end I said that Avery
refused to turn his camera on
um or something like that and then you
know uh I don't want to say anything
like I'm trying to think of something
like wacky but I don't want to say
anything and then Avery Avery Avery left
um because uh because 20 more Muslims
joined you know that is no longer my
book that's something new they they have
they've completely changed it made it
their own now so it's no longer the book
right right so yeah they can they can
write whatever they want but it's not
going to be the original and I think
that's the main point with the Quran
um I think I think it's fairly clear if
I'm being honest
okay so you're saying that that
rendition would not be the Quran anymore
right it would be some type of fake book
that they made up right
um I want to say something yeah but it
could also it could also contain element
of the Quran but it wouldn't be the
Quran anymore no more in in as a whole
no all right good so it would like what
we're just we're just saying it wouldn't
be the Quran anymore it would be a it'll
be a fake rendition with even maybe some
elements that it had of the truth in
there but it wouldn't be it would not be
the well no it would not be the quranism
right so it wouldn't be the Quran it
wouldn't be so this is what I'm so now
this is what I'm saying guys I'm saying
according to the Quran verses
um it it never addresses the Torah and
the gospel in such a way like that that
um some of it is good or or that it's
not the Torah and the gospel anymore
right it literally over and over again
um gives it Authority says that that
it's an authority to judge by to believe
in that Allah's judgments is are in it
that if they do not stand on the Torah
in the gospel then they have nothing to
stand on this chapter five verse 68 so
all of these verses talk about how the
Torah in the gospel in the possession of
the Jews and Christians are the Torah in
the gospel that if they do not follow
they are of the disbelievers okay so to
say that they're corrupted or changed or
altered or they're like there's some
truth and whatever that does not make
sense to me when I read the quran's
narrative I just I don't see that and
I'm being as real as I can no no I
appreciate the honesty and you know
we're trying to explain our perspective
on it so that hopefully you can you know
understand where we're coming from so
yeah I think that it is
um well first thing why the heck am I
the only one with my camera on bro why
am I signal though single out here
oh you were given permission yeah you
could turn your camera on bro if you
want I can yeah yeah now this whole time
yeah we're waiting for you our mods our
mods gave um you you access to do that
recently so you can oh yes guys I do not
know to work uh discourse I'm used to
stream yard and stuff guys I got you no
worries I mean if you could figure it
out great if not it's okay everyone can
look at me I don't mind but yeah I'm I'm
getting ready to to cook some food and
get on out of here but is there anything
I didn't want to leave without anybody
giving the last the last word or
something like I want to make sure I
hurt everybody yeah I just quickly want
to Freestyle my um my reiteration of of
our Point uh then pull up one Hadith
that our friend Fareed uh mentioned
um so quickly yeah so uh I again I think
that it's it's it's a misconstruation
and it's a conflation between when Allah
says the Torah and the gospel like think
about it Allah says they have nothing to
stand on if they don't if they don't
stand upon the Torah in the gospel if
anything that's that's saying that since
they don't have the Torah in the gospel
they stand on nothing that that's almost
what it sounds like the original torn
gospel basically they stand on nothing
if they don't stand on it and it's very
kind of congruent with the Ayah that
says that why do you accept parts of it
and reject parts of it like you know
like what you have because there are
parts that affirm you know the process
of them for example so why do they
accept things that they like and then
reject things that they don't like so I
think and also let me add that it is so
clear because the Quran is we the
Criterion we use it for whenever if we
read the Bible or the the the Old
Testament or anything to use it as okay
maybe this happened but if this
contradicts the Quran then it definitely
didn't happen because it's the criteria
so I think it's abundantly clear given
the criteria or sorry given the the
what's the word on look for the contents
of it that has been changed according to
the quranic standard because if God says
you know
um I'm trying to think about okay if God
says that they called the the king of
Egypt king and not pharaoh and then the
Book of Esther or or Xerxes or Xerxes or
whatever says that um
it's uh it's Pharaoh or something
instead now then we can't believe both
we have to take the Quran lastly I not
went on a bit so forgive me Fareed um
Allah has told you that the people of
the scripture have changed some of
Allah's books and distorted it and wrote
something with their own hands this is
bukhari 7523 so I think that is now
abundantly clear
oh no that that again that goes along
with the Hadith that I quoted from Evan
from ibika theater when he quoted
abukari Who quotes IBN abbasu says no
one can remove any of the words from any
of Allah's books so and but but they
only distort the meanings and change the
meanings and interpretation so I think
that that goes right in line with with
IBN Abbas says in sahih bukhari book 100
in the book of tawheed that no one can
change go in Allah's books and change
the words they can only change again
interpretation so again again again
the word
doesn't necessarily mean the actual word
but could be referring to the truth
value of it or the command of it like
Allah says right so that's why I made
that differentiation before that
differentiation that's made in the Quran
itself so around me fairly that's what
it says brother what do we mean that's
what it says do you know what
oh yeah yes his word and stuff but it's
not it doesn't say that um it's not
talking about his decree where ebony he
doesn't mention Allah's decree or
anything like because he doesn't because
that's my point
could mean the physical actual words it
could mean the decree and there's reason
to believe now that it means the decree
and not the word because of this report
that says you know Allah has told you
the people of scripture have changed
some of Allah's books and distorted it
and wrote something with their own hands
yes Facebook
pardon me
I'm saying yes like they they wrote
we'll go in circles but
um is there is there any way that I can
that I can contact you guys and like um
we can do this again I'd love to come
back and or you guys can come to my
stream I do I do the same thing bro yeah
yeah you can DM us on the three Muslims
you can DM me personally also Rami dot
El Khalil
um it's probably somewhere in the
description
for sure for sure right yeah I'll be
I'll be in touch guys and see when you
guys go live I like I said I also go
live on my channel and I open like I
literally before coming here I had a
panel where we we had some good
discussions with Muslims so you guys are
more than welcome to join me as well man
um this is this is pretty good content a
good conversation man some some people
don't like that we're this nice to each
other
um one one more thing I want to mention
just I guess for the sake of it um the
the Hadith that you mentioned
um we don't know the the grading on it
is like the whole book but that one from
what had been
um
no no from from IBN Abbas no I'm talking
about the other one I'm talking about
the one you mentioned sorry the one from
uh yeah
oh yeah that was just uh that was just
that was IBN just quoting quoting him
yeah um I don't I don't really you know
I don't think it said specifically what
book it was from yeah okay no I just
want to mention it to uh to be as as
accurate as possible but yeah thank you
for joining us bro we appreciate it
inshallah hopefully we can do this more
in the future and I'm glad that we had a
a mature and proper discussion on it and
I think that there's there's a lot more
that we can definitely expand on for
sure man for sure God bless you guys
thank you brother you too much I'll talk
to you soon all right you too bye-bye
all right now I gotta figure out how to
get out of here it's okay I'll put you
back in the waiting room right now okay
take care of it all right
yeah this believes in the revelations of
Allah they are no longer Muslim this is
one of the tenets of Islam one of the
six pillars of the men we cannot reject
the messages and we cannot reject with
this belief in the revelations and the
books that Allah has revealed that's in
the actual Revelation yeah however
never once wrote anything down or
ordered and you want to write anything
down the Bible that we have today is not
the Revelation so we don't deny tldr in
the revelations that were sent by Allah
two different Messengers
everything that is preached we believe
is straight from Allah however the Bible
today
I mean I don't know I don't know why
that's that's difficult to understand
bro yeah I um I don't know but um it is
what it is I think um I think it's
difficult with someone coming from it it
was a great conversation I really wanted
to ask him more about the time that he
had the pivotal moment in his life
but it is what it is all right yeah
alhamdulillah it's okay we could
definitely you know discuss with them
more in the future I think that this was
a pretty decent balance
um yeah I did want to give a quick um
yes
you're representing Islam and you're
having these horses the difference
between a successful conversation and
the heated
I guess argumentation bro is just other
a lot of the time
if you carry yourself with etiquette and
manners as opposed to someone always did
we're gonna have fruitful conversations
inshallah and at the very end even if
you agree to disagree they can't pull
any strings as in the non-muslims and
say that oh look at look at how Muslims
behave look at how Muslims Act
yeah yeah 100 percent
um I think that's a great point and I
think that's that's the approach we
should take for now on I know that a lot
of people like I mentioned at the
beginning and we were discussing this a
lot of people want the sound bites they
want the clips they want the gotchas
they want the you know uh the three
Muslims exposed God logic exposed God
Lodge refuted but okay I guess that's
what you guys want but when you're
speaking about dawa it's deeper than
just refutation refutation refutation
I've been doing this for a few years and
I could have gone into it like no that
was wrong actually that's actually
incorrect that you don't get anywhere
like that and and not only am I am I and
are we gonna push him away unnecessarily
but people who are watching us as well
like fire said we're going to be pushing
them away unnecessarily why is this guy
so heated why can't this guy try and
understand why can't this guy and like
yeah maybe it's a bit of an emotional
argument but people are emotional yeah
was emotionally intelligent these things
are important as Muslims and for someone
to say there's no room for that in Islam
they would be absolutely wrong about
that damn Rose I love you both will
think of Allah immensely
bless us all and to all the viewers and
above all else more so than to prove
Avery wrong or to refute him we want him
to be a Muslim and if we keep that at
the Forefront of our mind then there's
no US versus them or anything like that
because there's always been one message
yeah absolutely absolutely 100
bless you I think we're probably going
to end off the stream we won the
Christian Collins show and we got one so
uh
on Hell any final words bro
alhamdulillah this was
a very beautiful time alhamdulillah all
right
and with that being said
I shall always see you guys on the next
one like comment subscribe and share
this with your friend assalamu alaikum